au mois d'août c'est Paris tout nu et
Paris tout nu c'est très voix
[Musique]
la nuit tombée Paris au mois d'août
prend un autre charme celui des
terrasses tièdes et de la bière fraîche
et pour les Parisiens qui ne sont pas
partis les restaurants deviennent un peu
des clubs
[Musique]
j'avais été un des précurseurs ou du
Paris au mois d'août puisque vous avez
été des premiers a décidé d'ouvrir dans
votre profession alors tout le monde
ferme
dès les premiers jours dès la première
fois la première année
tous les clients qui se sont tournés au
mois d'août enfin comme c'est bien comme
c'est chic mais un travail agréable qui
s'est fait alors je me suis dit il y a
pas de raison que je change et vous avez
une clientèle là aussi un Paris ça
existe énormément alors les deux plus en
plus d'ailleurs vous avez vous avez déjà
beaucoup de gens de cinéma
qui tourne qui profite du monde du mois
d'août pour tourner en plein air en
extérieur à Paris alors que c'est
impossible encore l'année vous avez tous
des gens qui préparent les étoiles pour
la rentrée
la saison 3 commence plutôt maintenant
avant et commencer au 15 août au 10
octobre au moment du Salon de l'Auto
maintenant les pièces de théâtre
démarrent dès septembre alors ils sont
là au mois d'Ao pour préparer les pièces
de clientèle qui met tout acquise et qui
est déjà ma clientèle ils sont heureux
de revenir ici il y a beaucoup
d'éditeurs
[Musique]
le développement des transports aériens
fait que les gens se déplacent très
facilement ils ont bien à Paris sans
arrêt les gens de cinéma d'abord depuis
nombreux les gens de la mode beaucoup de
gens de la mode alors ce qui fait que
des fois ça donne un temps plus jeune à
la maison ce qui est pas mal d'ailleurs
très jolie fille elle est beau
mannequins les coverboy tous ce qui fait
un élément de vie la plus bronzée de
Paris
tout tout le monde est bronzé quand il
rentre alors il y a un air de un air de
vacances dans l'établissement aussitôt
des exemples d'avoir compris en fait
quatre générations de la même famille et
le grand-père le fils de petit-fils
derrière petit-fils c'est pas courant
mais j'ai jamais vu quand même beaucoup
défiler depuis 40 ans que je m'occupe à
peu près de cette affaire
presque tous les ans je suis à Paris au
mois d'août toutes ces ravissants
paraissent en voiture Paris au calme et
puis j'adore marcher à pied alors je
décide d'aller visiter un quartier comme
ça je mets ma petite voiture dans une
rue puis-je je rayonne je connais Paris
j'adore j'adore vraiment je trouve que
c'est très très joli par ici
je vais vous dire d'abord parce que ma
bien-aimée est à Paris voilà et puis en
second
j'attends un producteur américain et je
joins l'utile à l'agréable et puis il y
a la chanson Paris au mois d'août alors
les chansons l'amour le travail j'adore
faire les mois d'août et quand j'ai pas
des films je préfère parler moi
j'allais prendre mes vacances si je
prends de vacances
Paris au mois d'août débarrasser de 90%
de ses voitures et débarrasser d'une
grande partie de ces Parisiens Paris au
mois d'août c'est Paris tout nu et Paris
tout nu c'est très voix on retrouve la
ville telle qu'elle a été faite par des
siècles et des siècles de travail et
c'est vraiment très très beau je trouve
que Mario mois d'août est un immense
village
très riche d'histoire toute tout ce qui
a été paru ressort à chaque pierre et on
les voit et on les respire
toutes ces températures à toutes ces
saisons
évidemment l'agrément du mois d'août à
Paris c'est que moins de circulation
puis après du visage nouveau
d'habitude d'habitude il fait au mois
d'août mais enfin
un inconvénient c'est que on a envie de
passer les soirées en plein air enfin
dehors et on va bouffer souvent tout un
restaurant dehors et on bouge trop mais
alors finalement c'est pas
on a un bénéfice mais c'est un bénéfice
qui
alors je m'arrange toujours pour être à
Paris au mois d'août parce que je trouve
que c'est un des mots on profite
vraiment de cette ville par exemple
l'autre jour j'ai eu une journée de
liberté j'avais quelques courses à faire
j'ai pris ma voiture ce que je ne fais
jamais habituellement et j'ai pu la
garer devant tous les magasins où
j'avais fait ce qui est vraiment est un
rêve pour un parisien à l'heure actuelle
enfin absolument irréalable c'est une
ville que j'adore et je crois qu'on en
profite beaucoup mieux précisément dans
dans ce mois exceptionnel il y a des tas
de choses qu'on découvre et qu'on voit
et qui nous sont cachés tout le reste de
l'année le temps des lots
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est dur de travailler à
Paris au mois d'août non parce que moi
je prends rarement des vacances alors je
m'en rends pas très bien compte au
contraire c'est agréable mois d'août il
y a moins de monde il fait beau j'aime
beaucoup Paris il était bon vous
travaillez beaucoup en ce moment à Paris
mais est-ce que vous avez les moments de
liberté et comment les occuperai bien
les gens qui prennent des vacances parce
qu'ils ont travaillé toute l'année à
Paris et dans le métier que nous disons
nous ne travaillons pas toute l'année à
Paris les voyageurs beaucoup nous allons
en Espagne ou en Italie nous tenons des
films dans un endroit différent c'est
pour ça que ce que je dis mais n'est pas
valable enfin je veux dire ça me
concerne je veux dire ce n'est pas une
généralité je comprends au contraire
mille fois les gens qui travaillent
toute l'année à Paris qui sont enfermés
ou dans des bureaux ou à l'usine et qui
aspire à prendre un mois de vacances que
je trouve personnellement très peu si je
serais ravi que tout le monde puisse en
prendre deux
[Applaudissements]
enseigne les femmes à Paris au mois
d'août elles sont belles
ça ne veut pas tout dire
maintenant approche oui je lis ça
approche viens
bonjour
je vous aide à descendre un petit peu
difficile
[Musique]
en plein mois d'août
est tellement doux c'est vraiment la
femme là
et travailler à Paris au mois d'août
c'est pas le pénible non plus non ça
j'adore parce que je sais pas en août
c'est Paris un autre aspect il y a plein
de touristes en couleurs
au mois d'août comment le trouvez-vous
à Paris au mois d'août parce que je m'y
plais parce que Paris est très agréable
au mois d'août et beaucoup plus agréable
que les autres mois on n'a pas de
courrier on a pas de coup de téléphone
on n'a pas de visite on est parfaitement
libre il y a une circulation
relativement facile et on souffre donc
un manque enfin
ma gouvernante est en vacances c'est moi
qui fait mes courses pour le déjeuner je
trouve tout dans les magasins il y en a
suffisamment d'ouvrir je suis
parfaitement heureux comme ça
ce qui me plaît le plus c'est que Paris
redevient une vie humaine n'est-ce pas
en hiver c'est une ville mécanique c'est
une ville envahie par les voitures c'est
une ville envahie par les moteurs il y
en a encore on les entend mais c'est une
ville qui est tout de même faite pour le
piéton
et comme je suis piéton j'en profite on
peut aller voir des choses que l'on
n'aurait pas idée d'aller voir quand on
est en pleine bousculade d'hiver ou de
printemps hier j'avais un paquet à
retirer à la poste un paquet de livres
qui m'arrivait d'Allemagne je devais
leur tirer à la douane qui se trouve
dans l'hôtel des Postes j'en ai profité
pour visiter tout le quartier des Halles
que je n'avais pas remue depuis deux
trois ans mais il est plus tranquille
que jamais puisque les halles sont
partis c'est merveilleux c'est rempli de
merveilles j'avais vu ces maisons
autrefois mais je ne me les rappelais
plus très bien c'est un peu stache
nettoyer d'une bonté enfin incroyable
j'ai passé deux heures à traîner dans ce
quartier que je connais cependant
puisque j'ai travaillé dans les
imprimerie de ce quartier je l'ai vu à
toutes les heures du jour et de la nuit
j'étais parfaitement heureux j'ai passé
deux heures admirable
[Musique]